hello everyone this is ishonghu
i also have my colleagues say and jeff
tenji here today
we are all from microsoft deep speed
team our team has a group of system
researchers and engineers
who are enthusiastic about performance
optimization of large-scale systems
recently we have been focusing on deep
learning systems
optimizing speed to change v2
conversions
and speed to develop that leads to our
work on deep speed
a dl training optimization library
towards speed
and skill we will give you a deep dive
of the work
today this is the outline of the talk
so first i'll give an overview of deep
speed why we develop it
and what it is then i'll describe
highlights of the result and the
underlying techniques
as well as the software architecture
after that
jeff will talk about how to use deep
speed
then sen yang will walk over
tiring lg's 17 billion model training
as an example over there he'll highlight
some key techniques
like zero flexible combination of
parallelism
then 10g will give you another example
on the fastest
bird training we will conclude the talk
with upcoming features
so as we all know dl training is
challenging because it's too slow to
train high quality models
on massive data more specifically
more hardware may not bring higher
throughput for example
when communication is a bottleneck when
model size exceeds device memory
furthermore higher systems throughput
may not indicate faster conversions
this is where the dark part of deep
learning kicks in
where techniques such as large batch
scaling gradient compression
improves performance but could slow down
convergence
the last but not the least the
optimization ideas and techniques are
often scattered
how to use them collectively and
conveniently is non-trivial
so all these challenges motivate our
work on deep speed
deep speed strive for three is
efficiency effectiveness and easy to use
efficiency promote efficient use of
hardware for high throughput on single
device
and scalability across multiple devices
this is the hpc part of the outsystems
effectiveness promote for high accuracy
and fast convergence
we reduce the number of samples needed
to achieve high accuracy
lowering training cost this is where
machine learning theory intersects
with the system part
certainly easy to use makes earlier 2es
conveniently accessible to our model
scientists
to improve their development
productivity
what is deep speed deep speed is a dlr
training optimization library
on the software stack it sits between dl
models
and training framework among training
frameworks
we primarily support pi torch
pi torch user can leverage deep speed
with just a few lines of code changes
here is an example that the left hand
side is bird original and the right hand
side
is bert with deep speed as we can see
the primary change needed is to call
deep speed.initialize
to wrap the model and parameters then we
can use
wrapped model as deep speed engine to
perform forward
pass back or pass parameter update using
similar syntax as original
that's it just a few lines of code
changes
then deep speed will handle the
underlying performance challenges apply
efficiency and effectiveness
optimizations as appropriate
that leads to speed and skill
what kind of speed and skill deep speed
excels
in four areas model scale
speed result scalability and usability
i will talk about them one by one
first with respect to model scale
state-of-the-art models like a media
megatron rm
google t5 has about 10 billion
parameters
deep speed introduced a system
breakthrough 0
standing for zero redundancy optimizer
to conquer the memory and scaling
challenge
of very large models xero significantly
reduces memory footprint
while retaining compute and
communication efficiency
in the first stage zero one imparts deep
speed to 100 billion parameter models
efficiently
10x bigger than the largest published
models by them
leveraging this unique system capability
deep speed powered model training
of turin energy 17 billion parameter
model
the largest model until last month and
obtained
record-breaking accuracy
we continue to push for the frontier of
training systems
in early may we released zero two
which adds novel optimization on top of
zero one
and unblock 200 billion parameter model
training
on today's hardware
very recently we heard gpt3 from openai
it has a record-breaking model size of
175 billion parameters
i want to point out that the system
capability of zero two
would allow us to run search gigantic
models
furthermore we are working closely on
zero three
which could allow us to scale to models
of arbitrary size
as long as aggregate aggregated memory
of hardware
allows for example running one trillion
parameter model using
a thousand gpus please stay tuned
for that
besides skill deep speed also excel
in speed for very large models
such as those over 25 billion parameters
we observe
up to 10x faster throughput over
megatron lm a state-of-the-art model
parallelism approach
for example the figure here shows a
system throughput using deep speed
versus megatron rm
the workload is a gpt family of models
with size from 40
to 117 billion parameters
here the throughput of megatron rm is
normalized as
1x show as green bar and the throughput
of deep speed are shown
as blue bars megatron rm
use tensor slicing for model parallelism
primarily optimized for internal
parallelism but for model of search size
it needs to run them across nodes
then the limited internal network
bandwidth significantly degrade
performance on the other hand deep speed
combined
zero part data problem together with
tensor slicing of megatron
so zero improves memory efficiency it
fits
models using lower degree of model
parallelism
and allows for larger batch size
improving both computation
and communication that leads to up to
10x
higher throughput
on the third part with respect to
scalability
we have some interesting observations so
for people working on systems it is
normal to see sublinear speed up
with the increasing number of devices
perfect linear scalability is probably
the best to expect
can we do even better the answer is yes
sometimes with deep speed so the figure
here shows our system scalability visa
increase in number of gpus
the green curve shows a scalability
assuming perfect linear speed up
and the blue curve shows matter of
scalability results of deep speed
we can see that our measured scalability
is above the perfect linear speed up
line
achieving super linear speed up in other
words when we double the machines
way more than double the system's
throughput so what's going on
this comes from the power of zero when
we increase number of gpus we reduce
memory required per gpu to store model
states
so there are more device memory
available for activations
that allows higher batch size and
potentially higher gpu efficiency
and it brings super linear speed up
when we scale models towards many
devices
search superlinear speed up could reduce
the training time
substantially
last but definitely not the least deep
speed is easy to use
as we have already seen just a few lines
of code changes
we could enable deep speed on pi torch
models
furthermore to train large jobs
model parallelism is a major constraint
we eliminate that burden from developers
so for models up to 13 billion
parameters
deep speed users can stick to their
favorite
data parallelism without worrying about
model parallelism
in contrast without deep speed a model
with more than 1.4 billion parameters
will run
out of memory using data parallelism
alone
in summary we develop deep speed to
offer exceptional skill
speed scalability and good usability
next let's take a step further
look at some highlights of the
techniques which
enable those results
i listen in three categories efficiency
effectiveness
and usability efficiency
promote efficient use of single device
and class devices for example
zero redundancy optimizer zero
optimized for memory efficiency fastest
transformer kernels
optimized for compute efficiency spas
gradient
for communication efficiency overlapping
iovs compute
for io efficiency combination of
data and model parallelism for scaling
efficiency effectiveness
promotes for fast convergence for
example adaptive hyper parameter tuning
optimizers for large batch training and
so on
usability features make efficiency and
effectiveness features easily
accessible to our model developers
for example we set up boilerplate
features for distributed training like
mix precision
gradient compression gradient
accumulation
and so on such that our model scientists
can
focus on the model design we also
simplify io
checkpointing profiling which are all
essential for large job training
later on in the talk you'll see a few of
these techniques
in more details
this slide shows deep speed software
architecture that
house also how we put different
techniques together
in the software stack deep speed has
three parts
api runtime and ops i'll talk about them
one by one
if speed api is a thin layer
which is compatible with pi torch as you
have seen
our key api is deep speed.initialize
and we also have parameter json file
that
allow users to configure their training
settings
the second part is deep speed runtime
this is also the core part of deep speed
manage execution contact performance
optimization for example a deployed
training job
across distributed devices perform data
and model partitioning
conduct system optimization it also have
tuning model for effectiveness and
utility model
for failure detection and checkpointing
deep speed runtime is written in python
the third part of deep speed is deep
speed ops
this is our low level kernels written in
c plus plus and cuda
to optimize computation and
communication
examples are like ultra fast transformer
kernels fields land kernels custom
reduce
and so on next
i want to talk a bit on the ration now
for
us to choose search software
architecture there are two part
first that we perform optimization on
top of the training framework versus
closely coupled by doing that we can
well leverage the entire ecosystem
at the same time it's far easier to
maintain comparing with deep integration
secondly deep speed is infrastructure
agnostic
so our users can leverage deep speed on
their favorite
environment like hml air vms
npi based platform local nodes and so on
so that completes the overview of deep
speed
next i'll turn the flaw to jeff to talk
about
how to use deep speed okay
so today i'm going to talk to you about
deep speed and how to use it
and i urge you to check out our website
it's at deepspeed.ai
which is linked here
so specifically uh deepspeed uses pi
torch models
so what we kind of assume here is that
you have an existing
user model that's written using pi
torch's nn module
so the documentations here on the right
this essentially
uh you have implemented a forward pass
and your model parameters
and and so forth that's a fairly
standard kind of way in pi torch to
express your model
then the next step is modifying your
user code to actually use deep speed
so the way that this works is you import
deep speed and then you use our
initialize function so this is a deep
speed initialize which
then wraps your model this is kind of
similar to pytorch's uh distributed data
parallel in
sort of style but it provides several
additional features
so the required piece here is passing in
your model but you can also
all pass in additional pieces such as
optimizer learning rate scheduler
or data set if you want to use kind of
different features that deep speed
enables the next piece is updating
your python argument parser so what this
will do is it'll
modify the parser that you're using to
add some
deep speed specific flags and we'll talk
more about those in detail coming up
the deep speed initialize function
returns a wrapped version of your model
that you'll then use for forward
backward and parameter updates
which we'll go into much more detail
soon
once you have that then you can use our
deep speed launcher to actually
execute your training across all your
distributed nodes and gpus
uh the way that that works is you'll use
uh the deep speed
launcher which was which will be
installed with deep speed
you'll pass in the client your client
entry script and whatever client
arguments you have
and then add this flag called deep speed
config
which is the configuration json
associated with your deep speed run
where you can turn on and off various
features an example here is like if
you're training a c410 model it's like
just deep speed c410.i
and then the deep speed config
but what that buys you is it lets you uh
use deep speed
to then train across all of your
different distributed nodes so if you're
using 64 gpus
spread across multiple nodes physical
nodes this will do this launching kind
of seamlessly for you
it'll handle the environment propagation
data partitioning
and seamlessly kind of incorporate all
of the different system optimizations
that we've talked about
today and that will be talking about
soon
so let's look at a specific example so
this is a burp model
before we make our deep speed
modifications this is kind of what it
looks like
we construct a let's say this bur
multitask model for example
we would traditionally wrap this maybe
in a distributed data parallel module
and then after this we would construct
like the optimize our specific optimizer
and then if we want to do
fp16 training we would wrap this
as well then
after that we would do our forward pass
backward pass
and optimizer step as shown
here but now after applying deep speed
we
construct our model just like we did
before but now we want to actually wrap
this
with our deep speed initialize call like
we were talking about before
returns a model and then we do our
forward pass we're
very similar to before our forward pass
is the same but now our backward and
parameter updates are just
slightly different and they're with
respect to the model itself
for more details i definitely urge you
to check out this
this link what this is is it links to
our deep speed examples repository that
has all sorts of different
models that we've modified to use deep
speed such as bert in this case
the next step here is the deep speed
json file so this is this one
specifically we would use for burp
and what this does is it tells deep
speed let's say the the batch size that
you're training with so the total batch
size may be of 6 500
or 65 000 in this case and the training
micro batch size so this is the batch
size that you're actually training with
on each gpu so in this case this is 64
samples that each gpu would be training
with
instantaneously at that time and then in
addition
it what kind of optimizer you're using
so in this case this is lamb
what learning rate and sort of what
other hyper parameters that you want to
use
uh during your training then finally
turning sort of on and off the feature
of mixed precision so this is training
with fp16 so we could take advantage of
all those nice
tensor cores that are available on like
v100 gpus from nvidia for example or
that sort of thing um and again here's
there's a nice link to check out the
example if you want to dig into this in
more detail
so one more example we want to talk
about today is uh
megatron's gpt2 model uh so this is
nvidia's implementation of openai's gpt2
um on the left we have the original
version of this that
constructs the model does some fp16
kind of wrapping distributed data
parallel wrapping just like in bert
constructing the optimizer and kind of
doing some specific things
relating to fb16 training
and then just like before the forward
backward and parameter updates
now after applying deep speed uh this is
what it looks like
so we instantiate the model just like we
did before create our
our atom optimizer and then just do this
deep speed initialize call
and just like before as well we just
do our forward pass just like on the
left side but
our backward and parameter updates are
now with respect to the model
the the newly wrapped model
and we've included a handy link here
that links to the
modified gpt2 code in deep speed in our
deep speed
examples repository if you want to look
at the specific code changes
in more detail
and then lastly here we have the
deepspeed json file
for gpt2 and what this has
is on the right we have the train batch
size of 512
we have the atom optimizer fb16
training is enabled and now sort of one
key difference
is our zero optimization is set to true
so samyam
shortly we'll be talking about all the
features of xero and how it works
but the the nice part is that to turn it
on and off
is just essentially a flag in the in the
config so
uh turning it on and off is is quite
simple
with that i'll give it to samyam to take
over
the rest hello everyone
my name is samyam raj mandari i am a
researcher at microsoft and i work on
accelerating distributed
training at a large scale and today i'll
be talking about the deep speed library
in the context of large model training
so there are numerous challenges when it
comes to training a large model from a
system perspective
on one hand large models are
computationally intensive to the train
and on the other hand the amount of
memory required to train these models
can be several orders of magnitude
larger than the amount of memory
available
on a single gpu making it very difficult
to train these models
to address these issues deep speed can
significantly reduce the amount of
memory required for training
while at the same time it can also
improve the training throughput
during the training and also reduce the
amount of resources required to train
these models
making it accessible for many model
scientists to train large models
so to give an example in february of uh
this year microsoft trained the turing
nlg
17 billion uh it's a 17 billion
parameter gpt-like model
and it was the largest model at the
largest language
model at the time of its training to
just give
a quick context of how large this model
is
the table here shows the touring nlg 17
billion in comparison with
bird large as you can see in terms of
computation
this model has over a hundred times
than the bird large and in terms of
memory
just the memory footprint of the model
itself and the model states requires
about
275 gigabytes of memory compared to
5.12 gigabytes for bird large
so so given this it was quite impossible
to train this model using the
state-of-art technology at the time
with deep speed we were significantly we
were able to significantly reduce the
memory footprint
and also improve the throughput as well
as reduce the number of gpus required to
train this model
allowing um allowing us to
go from um just being completely
infeasible to train this model to
becoming practically possible
so i do want to point out that it is
possible to train this model without
deep speed as well
you could use existing state-of-the-art
technology like
tensor slicing or model parallelism such
as the one that is implemented in
megatron to train this model
in model parallelism you you split the
model states
across multiple gpus during the training
and
each gpu is responsible for doing part
of the computation
and it only holds part of the the model
parameters which allows you to train the
model without running out of memory
so here in this table we're showing the
configurations
required to train this model using the
state-of-the-art model parallelism
framework called megatron here you can
you can split the model with a 16-way
model parallelism
on a dgx2 node these nodes have
16 v100 nvidia gpus
each one of them have about 32 gigs of
memory
so even after splitting the model
into 16-way model parallelism we could
only fit a batch size of
8 per node so given this high level of
model parallelism and a small batch size
the amount of computation that is being
done on each gpu
is too small to be efficient so you can
see that the
throughput per gpu that we could achieve
during this training was about nine
teraflops
um to put this in perspective these v100
cards have over 120 teraflops in peak
performance
so it was achieving less than 10 percent
of the peak performance
and to add to that these gpt2 style
models are usually trained with a batch
size of 512 or larger
and given that we were we could only fit
a batch size of 8 per node
this means that you would need 1024 gpus
to just be able to train with a batch
size of five twelve
and so the given given this uh
prohibited prohibitively large amount of
gpus required to train this model and
this
really inefficient training it was quite
infeasible to train this model
so deep speed addresses this issue using
a memory optimizer
in it called the zero redundancy
optimizer with zero redundancy optimizer
we are
significantly able to reduce the memory
footprint for this training
allowing us to train the same model with
just four-way model parallelism instead
of 16
and with that we are able to fit a batch
size of 32 per node
and so now because you have smaller
model parallelism degree and a larger
batch size
we can get a much higher efficiency per
gpu so we're able to achieve
over 30 teraflops of performance per gpu
so that's a 3x improvement in throughput
and now since we can also fit
a four times larger batch size of 32
we only need 256 gpus to fit
the batch size of 512. so with this
it was possible to to train this model
so
the the next natural question is uh how
does the zero redundancy optimizer
reduce the memory footprint
so before we get there let's first talk
about uh the standard
data parallel training that is usually
used to train
models across multiple gpus
so in standard distributed data parallel
training
we are trying to train the data parallel
training loop that is shown on
the left side of this slide on
a distributed gpu cluster where this
loop
is being executed on each one of the
different gpus
each gpu loads a different mini batch it
has
it also has the model states that are
replicated across all the gpus
and so each gpu executes the forward
pass
computes the loss on its mini batch then
it
computes the backward propagation to get
the gradients
then these gradients are averaged across
all the gpus once these gradients are
averaged
each gpu then in parallel computes the
updates to the model states
and the model parameters then it applies
those updates to its model parameters
and that completes one iteration of of
training
so here the figure
at the bottom the first row shows the
memory map
while training a model using distributed
data training
the first row shown in blue represents
the memory consumed by the parameters
the second row in orange shows the
memory consumed by the gradients
and the big chunk in green
shows the memory consumed by the
optimizer states
so this could be for an optimizer like
atom it could be your momentum and
variance
and if you are training your model in
mixed precision
then it could also be a 32-bit copy of
the
of the parameter themselves so the key
thing to note here is that
these optimizer states gradients and
parameters
which we collectively call the model
states they are
replicated across all the different gpus
in
in distributed data parallel training so
the way
zero works is by removing this
redundancy across these gpus
so since since there are three different
types of model states
uh there are three different phases of
zero
each one of them removing the redundancy
for
for for one of these states so for
example the first stage of zero removes
the redundancy in optimizer state
that's shown in the second row um the
second stage optim uh really
removes the redundancy in the
gradients and the third stage removes
the redundancy
in optimizer states gradients as well as
the parameters
and it removes that redundancy by simply
partitioning these model states across
gpus instead of replicating them so here
to just give a flavor of how
xero works uh we're gonna dive deeper
into
stage one of of zero
so stage one partitions to optimize the
states instead of replicating them
in terms of computation everything works
quite similar to how things work in
standard data parallel training
where each gpu loads up its own mini
batch
then it performs a forward propagation
and backward propagation on that mini
batch
during the backward propagation each one
of the gpus is computing its gradients
with respect to that mini batch
and then those gradients are averaged
now after that
instead of each gpu updating all the
parameters
each gpu only updates a small portion of
the parameters
a small partition that belongs to that
gpu
once that partition is updated then the
gpus perform an
all gather operation so that these
updated partitions
can be sent to all the remaining gpus so
that each gpu has its entire set of
parameters
updated so that's zero stage one
um let's take a a an even deeper dive
into
into this um so let's say we're trying
to train
um a transformer based model with uh 16
transformer
layers like a bird large across two gpus
right so the the cells here
shows the memory footprint of uh for
training this model for standard data
parallelism
on each gpu you have memory to store
the fp16 parameters so here i'm talking
about a mixed precision training which
is the standard way of
of training these gpt2 like models on on
model
on modern architectures which have
significantly improved throughput for
for computation using these fp16 data
types
so you have these fp16 parameters then
you have the fp16 gradients
and then you have your optimizer states
in fp32 so if you're using an atom
optimizer then
you may have your momentum and your
variance you may also have fp32
gradients and fp32 parameters
and of course to train the model you
also need
memory to store your activations so this
is standard data parallelism
with zero stage one you partition the
optimized states across
gpus so each gpu only keeps half of the
optimizer states
then just a standard data parallelism
you perform forward propagation
through the transformer blocks
you compute your loss and then you
compute
your backward propagation and compute
your gradients
so now once the gradients are computed
since gpu 0 only needs to update the
first half of the parameters and gpu one
only needs to update the second half of
the parameters
gpu0 will receive the first half of the
gradients from
gpu one
and gpu one will receive the second half
of the gradients
from gpu 0 and then each one of these
gpus can then average these gradients
then using these average gradients now
each one of the gpus can update its
model states
then it can update its parameters and
once the parameters are updated
now you perform an all gather where gpu0
sends the updated parameters from gpu
zero to gpu one
and gpu one sends the updated parameters
from gpu one
to gpu zero and so that completes a
single iteration
of training using the zero stage one
optimizer inside deep speed
okay so now coming back to training the
touring in lg 17 billion
this model was trained using zero stage
one and stage one
can provide up to four x reduction in
memory
it was trained using a combination of
zero stage one
and model parallelism and the reason why
we can do that is because xero can work
with tensor slicing based model
parallelism frameworks such as
megatron lm and the way it interacts
with
this uh model parallelism implementation
is through a simple api
um that that requires uh the model
parallelism framework to pass
in a model parallel unit object all that
object does is implement these two
methods
the first one the get data parallel
group that returns the list of gpus that
are involved
in data parallel training and the second
one called get
model parallel group that simply returns
the the list of processes that are
involved in model parallel training
so deep speed and xero does not need to
know
how model parallelism is implemented
it just needs to know which gpus are
involved in model parallel training
and as long as you can get that
information deep speed and xero will
work with
with model parallelism so with that
here's a recap of the results
using zero with megatron we were able to
reduce the model parallelism degree by a
factor of four
we're able to increase the batch size
also by a factor of four
which meant that we can reduce the total
number of gpus required to train the
model from 1024 to 256
and by decreasing the model parallelism
degree and
increasing the batch size we were seeing
over 30 teraflops in performance
compared to nine teraflops
when using megatron alone without zero
and deep speed
so as we mentioned earlier zero actually
has three different stages
the first stage as we saw earlier it
reduces the memory by up to four times
with stage two we're able to further
reduce the memory by eight times
and with stage three you can reduce the
memory
proportional to the number of gpus that
you are using
and all of this memory reduction comes
from very modest
to no increase in the amount of
communication volume during the training
so for example with stage 3
you're increasing the communication
volume by about 50
compared to the standard data parallel
training however with stage 1 and stage
you're getting up to 8x reduction in
memory
without any communication overhead so
the communication is
exactly the same as in standard data
parallel training
so currently in deep speed uh we've
implemented stage one and stage two
and what this allows you is to train
models with up to 13 billion parameters
without requiring any model parallelism
and it can train models with up to 200
billion parameters when combined with
model
parallelism on today's gpu clusters such
as the dgx2 clusters with
16 nvidia v100 uh gpu cards
so so far we've been talking about zero
and how how it reduces the memory
by partitioning the model states in
addition to
reducing the memory from model states
xero also has a bunch of more optimize
optimizations that allows reduction in
memory from other components
so for example just like how model
states are replicated across multiple
gpus in data parallel training
activation memory during training can be
replicated across
multiple gpus during model
parallel training and so zero can remove
the redundancy
in activation memory by partitioning the
activations across these model parallel
gpus
you can also offload these activation
memories to cpu
if you don't have enough memory to train
extremely large models
the next optimization that xero can do
is convert
fragmented memory to defragmented memory
on the fly during training
so so during training if your memory is
fragmented
you might still run out of memory even
when you have
uh enough memory available during the
training
just because you can't allocate a single
contiguous
uh buffer to satisfy a memory request
even though there might be enough
fragmented memory um
that can satisfy the request if they
were contiguous
so so so in xero the memory
defragmentation
will on the fly defragment these memory
fragments so that all the memory is
contiguous
and you are able to satisfy these larger
memory requests
so with with all these different memory
optimizations
with the with the second stage of zero
uh
uh model state optimizations um
we are able to uh train models with up
to 200 billion parameters
up to 10 times faster than current state
of the art we call this implementation
0 stage 2 which is already in deep speed
next i would like to ask
tunji to talk about the second
use case scenario for deep speed uh by
presenting the world's fastest
bird training thank you everyone
hi i'm tunji i'm a researcher at
microsoft
i work on system support for large-scale
deep learning
now i'm going to be talking about how we
achieve the world's fastest training
time on the burt large model
using the deep speed library
so with using deep speed we're able to
complete
uh training the large model in 44
minutes
on a 1024 nvidia view 100 gpus
compared to the previous published
record of 67 minutes that was reported
by nvidia
using the same number of gpus of the
same generation
this table here goes into a bit more
details about our scalability
as you can see we are able to scale
close to linearly as we
increase the number of nodes from 1 to
64.
so in terms of the technology in deep
speed that allows us to achieve
this training time um they're basically
two
aspects to them one there are efficiency
optimizations which
target single gpu performance and this
a collection of optimizations enable us
to achieve
over 50 percent of the peak throughput
on an nvidia v100 gpu
the second class of optimizations are
the effectiveness
optimizations this are techniques that
allow us to converge
um on large batch training using fewer
samples so collectively this
optimizations the
convergence optimizations allow us to
converge
with 422 million samples compared to the
baseline of 512 million samples
the efficiency optimizations that i'll
be talking about today include
optimized transformer kernels
overlapping
i o with computation and sparse output
processing
the effectiveness optimizations that
i'll be talking about
include are the fact that we train using
mixed sequence length training
with a batch size of 64k a lamp
optimizer
learning rate schedules and pre-layer
normalization
so first i'll talk about the single gpu
optimizations
specifically the kernel fusion
here i'm showing an image of the
transformer block
highlighting the various computations
in the transformer execution such as the
query key in value matrix computations
which are reflect uh highlighted using
this colored blocks
so each of these blocks involves
a kuda kernel call and each call comes
with its overhead
and so the idea behind canal fusion is
to
derive a number of benefits the first of
which
is to reduce the kernel call overhead by
having fewer kernels
the second benefit is that by
fusing kernels together we increase the
amount of work that's done
within each call which helps to improve
the gpu utilization
another benefit is that some of these
kernels
have same input data which have to be
read from global memory
and so by fusing them together we can
get away with reading the data
only once rather than repeatedly which
helps to improve the data locality
and simultaneously reduce the memory
bandwidth requirements
within the transformer for bird we
identified two classes of
candidate kernels for fusion the first
class of
kernels are the parallel kernels such as
the query
key and value kernels which execute
independently
and so can be fused easily the second
class of kernels are the producer
consumer kernel
such as the dropout and residual input
which are added together and fed
into layer normalization that goes into
the feed forward
this can also be fused easily
so now i'll go into an example of how we
fuse the qkv
kernels and thereby improve their
locality
and reduce uh memory bandwidth
requirements
here on the left i'm showing the
baseline uh
qkv kernels and include and also the
transform
transform versions of this kernels
that as executed in the pi touch code
the blue lines here are representing the
data flow during the forward pass and
the red lines are represented in the
data flow during the backward pass
on the right hand side i'm showing the
fused kernels within deep speed
and here we can see a number of
differences
first we see if we focus in on the
forward pass we see that
rather than have three reads of the
input into the individual kernels we can
reduce that to just a single read
similarly on the backward pass rather
than having the qkv
kernels right uh generate three rights
to global memory we can reduce that to a
single right to global memory
in this way we're improving the data
locality and reducing the
bandwidth requirements on global memory
the other class of single gpu
optimizations we have
are involve the invertible operations
invertible operations are the ones where
the backward pass
is independent of the input and in
transformers we identify two classes of
such operations
the soft max and layer normalization
the benefit of invitable operations is
that it can help to reduce the
activation memory footprint because we
no longer need to save the input
activation memory on the forward pass
to be consumed on the backward pass
since the backward pass is independent
of the input another benefit is that
invertible operations can also be easily
fused with other operations and so we do
not need to save intermediate results
in the cases where they have a producer
consumer relationship with other
operations
so here i will illustrate an example
using the invertible
soft max on the left i'm showing the
base the baseline soft max computation
graph
in pi torch and what i'll draw your
attention to is the fact that
on the inputs on the input we have to
save the
input activations which are represented
with the x1 to xn
tensors and on the output we're saving
the output softmax which are the s1 to
sn
tensors if we compare this to the
computation graph in deep speed
we see that we no longer need to save
the input
activation because we can reformulate
the computation the softmaster
computation to become
independent of the input so we can
compute the gradients
without relying on the input and so this
allows us to avoid
saving the activation and thereby save
memory
the other single gpu optimizations that
we have
uh include overlapping of io and
computation and sparse output processing
let me briefly talk about those for the
overlapping i o and computation what we
do here is we prefetch the next input
batch into cpu
while the gpu is processing the current
batch
by doing this we're able to avoid the
data loading and tokenization overheads
that
is required we're able to move that off
the critical path
so that when it's time to process the
next input batch we are simply just
moving from cpu to gpu
which is a lot faster than if we were
written directly from disk
the second optimization is the sparse
output processing
so in the output we observe that only 15
of the mass tokens are actually required
and so there's significance
positive uh in in the computation
um this output of course is then fed to
the projection and
uh cross entropy is performed on it but
we do not need to do this for
all of the applicable tokens only for
the mast ones
which we observe to just be 15 and so
this is what this optimization looks
like
so first on the left is we can imagine
is the initial output
and by applying this mask on it we're
able to shrink the output down
into smaller uh into smaller size in
particular for
birth we observe that we are able to
reduce computation by 85 percent
using this optimization
so combining all of these optimizations
together we are able to improve the
performance
for birth training both on the sequence
land 128 and sequence led 512.
first i'll showing the single gpu
results for the sequence length 128.
here we can observe that one we're able
to train with larger batch sizes eighty
percent
larger batch size compared to nvidia
kernels
also we're able to train at 26 percent
faster throughput
compared to the nvidia kernels
on the sequence land 512 results we
observed similar improvements
we're able to train with 80 larger batch
size compared to nvidia kernels
and we're able to train at a 28 higher
throughput
compared to the nvidia kernels
now i'll switch to the convergence
tuning optimizations which help to
improve the effectiveness of our
training
the first class of such of this
optimizations
has to do with the lamp optimizer so
lamb optimizer is a layer wise gradient
adaptation optimizer which basically
tries to clip
the gradient values within a range and
in our
implementation of the lamb optimizer we
make it composible for users to
configure the mean and max coefficients
for the clipping
and here i'm showing exactly the values
that we use
for our training here i'm also
illustrating the
what the histogram of the gradients look
like for the sequence 128 and sequence
training and here we can see that the
optimizer is able to clip and keep the
gradients within this
specified ranges
the second class of convergence union
optimization has to do with the learning
rate schedule
so here we found that using a cyclic
schedule with dk
and doing a re-warm-up when we start the
5-12 sequence length
portion of the training or is very
effective to enable us to get
convergence
uh um using a few number of data
fewer number of data samples
the last class of convergence tuning
optimization is the layer normalization
so layer normalization is a technique
for improving training stability when we
train at very large batch sizes
it helps to avoid vanishing and
exploding gradients
a layer normalization can be applied
before
or after the attention layer
um and when it's applied before the
attention layer we refer to that as
priya pre-ln
and if we supply it after the attention
refer to that as post ln
it turns out that the placement is
pretty significant it has a significant
impact on convergence
and so here we're showing on the right
hand side the plot comparing the priya
ln
versus the postal land and as we can see
if we apply
post ln the model actually diverges
pretty early on during the training
but with the priya land uh layer
normalization
we're able to train effectively uh even
for a batch size as large as 64k
so in summary uh we're able to achieve
the fastest trading time with bert
using the deep speed library and this is
possible using two
classes two directions of optimizations
of effect
efficiency and effectiveness and the
fact that these two optimizations are
independent means that we get a
multiplicative effect by combining them
so in summary the efficiency
optimizations enable us to uh
to achieve 50 percent of the peak
throughput on the
on an nvidia v100 gpu and
on the effectiveness side this allows us
to train with 18
fewer data samples using 422 million
samples
compared to the baseline of 512 million
and the great thing about this set of
optimizations is they are widely
applicable
across models beyond birth it can be
applied to all
transformer kernels
before i round up i like to tell you
about some of some interesting upcoming
features that we have
in in in future releases of deep speed
the first one is the zero stage three
which samyam talked about earlier
here we'll be able to achieve a linear
reduction of the memory footprint of
parameters
corresponding to the data parallelism
degree of our training
this will enable us to train trillion
parameter models
using commodity hardware the second
class
of features that will you can look
forward to in
in deep speed are the sparse
transformers spas transformers will
enable us to train
sequences that are 10 times longer than
is currently possible today
and we'll be able to treat them fast
five times faster that is possible today
for more new and exciting features you
can go to our repo
on github or check out our our breaking
news and
breaking news page and documentation on
our website
www.deepspeed.ai
so this brings us to the end of this
webinar thank you very much for your
attention
and we look forward to taking your
questions in our live q a which follows
on
hello everyone thank you for attending
the gypsy webinar
and our live q a we have four members of
this meeting here i'm isha
hi guys my name is samyam rasmundari
thank you for tuning in
hi i'm jeff risley uh thanks for thanks
for tuning in
hi i'm tunjuruwashi thanks for joining
us today
over the next 20 minutes we are going to
answer
top questions submitted by the audience
let's get started
our first question is when does
xero show memory and throughput
improvement
does xero have a huge performance
penalty
so um uh hi guys uh i'll i'll take this
question
um zero can show performance improvement
in
in several different scenarios one of
the scenarios
is recently um um so i'll talk about
both deep speed as well as
zero on the deep speed side recently we
released the transformer based kernels
so if you
are using any transformer based model uh
deep speed is gonna give you
a significant performance improvement um
on the zero
side of things xero will show you a big
performance
improvement when your model is really
large and you cannot fit the model
in a lot of cases when you are just
using standard data parallelism
you can't even train a model with over
a billion parameters without requiring
significant changes to the model itself
using things like
model parallelism techniques like
megatron
but with xero you can just use
uh your your standard model that you
created in pytorch
and and xero can partition those models
and reduce the memory footprint
allowing you to not only run these
models but also run these models
at decent batch sizes which gives you
significant
computation efficiency allowing you to
get the speed up
and so one common question that we we
see a lot
is what about the overhead of
communication that zero incurs
is it gonna um perform worse than
standard data parallelism
and uh the answer to this question is
that
if we consider zero stage one and stage
two which is what is currently in deep
speed there is actually no additional
communication overhead of deep speed
and zero compared to standard data
parallelism so there is going to be no
loss in performance compared to standard
data parallelism for smaller models
and for larger models where you can't
train
the model with data parallelism or even
when you can
the the throughput is really slow
because of a small dash size
as you can significantly improve the
performance in those
scenarios
thank you zayn our next question is
do we need to specify the hardware
configuration
and binding while training or deep speed
handles it
automatically from inside the module
jeff would you like to take this
question please
sure hi everyone um so in terms of
how deep speed essentially is able to
discover your environment is we rely on
pi torch
to give us essentially access to the
gpus or or
cpu in some cases but you don't really
need to specify
much of anything of your hardware and
level environment
what we do sort of assume and urge you
to check out our documentation for some
additional details
is uh connectivity between machines so
if you're trying to scale out your
training to
do multiple nodes then you'll need to
set up
essentially passwordless ssh between the
nodes
uh this is similar to kind of
requirements and like mpi environments
and and so forth
um but once you have that piece set up
then
beefspeed's able to essentially scale
out the training for you
and communicate across all the different
nodes and so forth
thank you jeff our next question is
does deep speed support single gpu are
only
for multiple gpus kenji would you like
to take this one
oh yes i will you've shown thank you
yeah so
this speed provides benefit at pretty
much every
scale level so from a single gpu
scenario to
a single node which has multiple gpus to
a multi-node and
scenario well this bit provides benefits
uh performance uh triplet benefits at
every level of of
the scale and so for single gpu for
example we have
um basically uh optimized uh
kernels that helps to improve the single
gpu performance
beyond what is normally possible with
what other frameworks and also we have
techniques such as overlapping of the i
o
and the computation which also improves
the single gpu performance
within a single node we have our
distributed uh
training framework is highly optimized
so that it helps to get the
linear scaling within a single node and
when you go across
nodes and where techniques such as model
parallelism starts to hurt
when you have to cross nodes uh the zero
optimizer helps to
reduce the uh the need for model
parallels and that has to cross it go
across nodes
and so that way you can get close to
linear scaling as well as you go
across nodes even for very large models
and so yeah so regardless of what
your usage scenario is this speed has
some benefit for you
in terms of improving your throughput
for your training workload
thank you kenji okay yet another one
what types of models can benefit from
deep speed
i saw that most examples are nlp models
with deep speed work for image models
gun types of
models model machine translation models
austere models say would you like to
take this one please
sure so there there is nothing special
about the the nlp model uh that
that we are targeting in in deep speed
the
optimizations that we've developed are
fully general and they will
uh span across all different types of
models
for example our our communication
backend is optimized
um and so if you have for example
uh sparse embeddings you you can use the
the deep speed sparse communication uh
to to optimize those
um anything that uses a transformer
kernel you can use transformer both on
the image side and on the nlp side
uh you can take advantage of the
optimized kernels uh in deep speed
library to
to speed those up um if your model is
too large then zero will
work regardless of whether it's a nlp
model or
or something else so basically we've
we've identified
the common uh dl training pipeline that
is common across all these different
types of models from different domains
and we've optimized those so that when
you do switch across domains
those optimizations will still help
thank you zayn okay yet another question
uh what training data set do you use for
birth pre-training
and how do i get access
kenji would you like to answer this one
yes uh thank you xiang so yeah for the
birth training data set
uh we uh we'd initially internally use
like an internal data set but recently
uh in the
in our latest release and it's available
now in our github
we provided uh uh the ability to use the
nvidia
uh data set uh for bird training uh the
virtual
dataset that comes from nvidia this
which is open source so
um if you go to our get our github you
will be able to do that right away we
have uh already provided instructions
for doing the end-to-end training with
this data set
and so there shouldn't be any blocker
concerning that
thank you it looks like that we have
time for
one more question today
okay here is a question can i use the
fast transformer kernels on
other models beyond birds and
how do i do that
i guess kenji that you
are going to take this question again
sure so uh the fast transformer of
kernels
uh can benefit if you have a birth like
or transformer type
model because they're the optimizations
they are specifically
targeted for the transformer uh kernels
and so
uh so if you do have any kind of sort of
transformational
uh model you'll be able to take
advantage of this optimizations
and in terms of how you will use it
you can sort of we have documentation of
how we've applied this to the
uh to the model and that could be a
starting point
for you to start using it for your own
model
and um and as always we are always
uh available to help if you know if you
have if if your
own models deviate in some way or the
other and we we're very responsible on
our github and so you can
definitely like to hear back from you if
you have any issues that
come up as you apply this uh this
optimized kernels but
they're designed to be generally
beneficial for transformative
computations
thank you and thank you all for
attending today
we appreciate your participation and
interest in deep speed
if you'd like to learn more or even
better try out deep speed
please visit our website deeply.ai and
our
github ripple so these links are
provided in the results list
to the right of your screen in the
results list
there are also links to our technical
paper and blogs
we look forward to hearing your feedback
we hope that this feed makes the
training of your exciting deep learning
models
easy efficient and effective
thank you and have a great day
you